Aujourd'hui on va parler de ballons! mais
de ballons...
qu'on éclate !
Vous ne le savez peut-être pas, mais un
ballon peut éclater de deux façons différentes.
Si on gonfle modérément, puis qu'on le perce,
on va se retrouver avec deux fragments différents, deux morceaux.
Si on gonfle à bloc jusqu'à ce qu'il
éclate,
on va se retrouver avec plein de petits morceaux.
Des chercheurs du Laboratoire de Physique Statistique de Paris
se sont intéressés à ce phénomène.
Pour cela, ils ont utilisé un dispositif dédié, avec une caméra ultra rapide...
avec une caméra ultrarapide
et un système pour gonfler des feuilles de latex.
Ils se sont rendu compte que plus la surface est tendue,
plus la fissure va se déplacer rapidement
à la surface du ballon.
Et c'est justement cette vitesse de déplacement
qui va déterminer la forme de la fissure.
Une fois que la fissure atteint une vitesse limite,
elle se sépare en deux nouvelles fissures.
C'est ce qui aboutit au réseau de fissures
qu'on voit sur les images.
Cette vitesse limite, les chercheurs l'ont mesurée :
570 mètres par seconde.
Plus de 2000 km/heure !
Cette recherche paraît donc un peu loufoque,
mais en fait elle est très sérieuse...
Elle permet de mieux comprendre
la fragmentation des matériaux,
ce qui a des applications dans des domaines très variés
comme l'aéronautique ou le génie civil.
... tout ce qui est science des matériaux, en fait!
Et donc, bien au-delà de la fragmentation du latex !
Même si une fissure dans le latex...
ça peut avoir des conséquences... non négligeables :)
Hé pssst! Abonnez-vous !